so that's my story of how i got into uk
medical school without doing uk cats a
levels bmats or any other international
university entrance exams hello i'm
zailihar i'm a third year medical
student studying in the uk so i came to
this country when i was 16 so i did
university foundation year in an
international college in the uk
university foundation year exam a
university foundation year qualification
is a lot i guess a lot easier than a
levels and any other university exams
medical schools considered the
qualification that i had lower than they
require for that reason i couldn't apply
to medical schools and then i did get
into medical sciences through clearing
if you don't know what clearing is
throwing is a system that is used by uk
universities when their spaces for that
specific course has not been taken so
they have empty spaces so they need more
students for that reason getting into
courses through clearing is a lot easier
because those universities want students
to get into the course so that they can
fill in the spaces
so they lower their interior
requirements for example and usually
they want a srsi staff for that course
but if you got in
through clearing then actually you would
have probably got in with lower grades
for example with bbb or aaa rather than
a star because actually they want you to
fill in that space the reason that i
applied for that medical sciences course
in that university because i did
research i knew beforehand that that
university offers a transfer scheme from
medical sciences course to medicine so
now i'm going to talk about what a
specific requirements i need to fulfill
to transfer from medical sciences to
medicine
firstly like in every degree in medical
sciences also there are a number of
assessments so exams and projects that
you have and at the end of the year the
average of all of those exams that you
had throughout the year is being taken
and if your average is in top 10 amongst
all of the
the first year medical sciences students
then they let you have a medical school
interview and if you pass that interview
then they let you go into medicine
starting from first year because i had
the highest average amongst all the
first year medical sciences students in
my year which is
220 or 250 it was for my year i had the
opportunity to have that
medical school interview with nine other
top students once we passed interview we
got into medicine there is something
important to note not all universities
actually do have a transfer scheme that
allows you to get into medicine from
another course like medical sciences or
biology or biomedical sciences like that
um i think at the time that i've applied
which was like four years ago on the
four universities actually allowed you
to transfer from one degree to medicine
that was at the time university of
newcastle queen mary london and
university of exeter which i'm going to
currently so i went into university of
exeter's medical sciences then
transferred to medicine and i didn't
have to do uk cat to transfer either and
i didn't have to do a levels i didn't
have to do any of those
um but actually at the moment university
of exeter has stopped that transfer
scheme from medical sciences to medicine
because it was oversubscribed most of
the students who were in the first year
of medical sciences were actually there
because they wanted to get that transfer
to medicine and once they don't get the
transfer they would drop out so exotical
school to stop that transfer scheme now
but it's important to note that it's a
lot easier to get into medicine to get
into medical schools in the uk through a
levels or b-tech or any other kind of
exams then getting into medicine through
a transfer scheme because everyone who
was in the first year of medical
sciences almost everyone like nine to
five
of my cohorts i remember in the first
day in the first lecture of our year in
medical sciences one of the tutors
lecturers asked us who was in that
course to actually get into medicine in
that lecture hall almost 95 of my peers
raise their hands so almost 95 of your
cohort will actually will be there
hoping to get into medicine so for that
reason i'd say if you want to get into
medical school in the uk do a levels or
b tech which is a lot less competitive
as i've also talked to my friends who's
done a levels to get into medicine they
said it's a lot easier to get into
medicine that way rather than go through
this transfer scheme and then also it
saves you a year i hope this was helpful
please let me know if you have any
questions i'm more than happy to answer
them
[Music]